nature children and old people are the
three greatest teachers we ever had the
mask has created not just social
distancing but emotional distancing one
of the worst things that we hear as kids
and especially as little boys is what
are you going to be when you grow up
that would change your whole life and
there he is mr. Preston smiles
what's up my man I love all the people
who whose energy introduces them before
they even say anything like you gotta be
one of the top ten always bringing
always being the energy always bringing
the love so I first connect with Preston
and his wife Alexi uh three years ago
yeah 20 17 or 16 well you just had your
book come out I don't think you are in
Australia at the time we're doing some
doing that workshop Bridge methods I
love it so and now you seem to have
transitioned the the business to help
coaches make more money mm-hmm so so
talk to me about kind of what's going on
the past three years and the evolution
of Preston smiles
yeah man I'm definitely gonna go into
that but I just want to present a few
things one how are you as a human I I
love it see I'm great man I'm here in
Toronto you know I think we caught the
whole cover thing pretty quickly so
we're not we're not super panicking
we're in we're in lockdown mode
quarantine mode but every everybody my
family everybody's super safe yeah how
about you are you are you and you're on
the west coast right yeah I'm in LA I'm
in LA and do you have kids
I have a son yeah how old is he ten
turns 11 in June jeez Louise okay and
how is that like homeschooling him or
are you yeah so he's got he's got online
classes that he has to go through I do
he finishes it pretty quickly
which is which is you know good so then
it's finding other things to do so
we have a nightly League of Legends game
that we play together so it's a video
game and also kind of teaching life
lessons through video games which is
always fun yeah so the beginning its
yeah I love this to be honest dude I'm
an introvert you know I know I know you
speak around the world I spent a whole
chunk of last year speaking this is
default easy for me like just being home
it was just me you know close family and
that's it just at home all day I'm down
for that
but doesn't just help my mission as much
but this is not I'm not faking like the
social anxiety like oh my god I can't
wait to get back out there yeah
billy-ben so same same in the sense of
there's a few things that I'm loving
about this whole conversation and
there's a few things that are
highlighting things that don't work
about our society and about how I've
been operating one even just this right
like I just went on a walk with my son
and I live in this neighborhood that's
like Pleasantville everybody has kids
everybody's about 35 to 45 and
entrepreneurs and that whole kind of
thing and the mask has created not just
social distancing but emotional
distancing in the neighborhood where
everybody previous to coke at 19 was
hearts open hey how are the kids like
that kind of thing where it's turned
into like are you my enemy and are you
gonna kill my kids right right and that
has been a very interesting thing to
keep cleaning up in my own consciousness
because I know I'm the source of all of
these things and so daily I'm actually
having to and getting the the
opportunity to continuously relook at
how I'm being and what's actually true
and real Shakespeare said a coward lives
a thousand deaths and I've heard that
and and thought about it and then I
started to think about how a lot of us
are doing that now where we're mentally
rehearsing for worst-case scenarios when
in truth in fact in real time what's
really here is this beautiful beating
heart amazing
friends and family and people who love
me the sun is shining the trees are
reaching towards the Sun all kinds of
amazingness is happening now and yet I'm
I've noticed in my clients and even in
myself at times getting caught into sort
of the vortex of the the conspiracies
and the looking at society and going is
this real
that I began to mentally rehearse
something that I don't actually want to
experience and therefore the but the
cells of my body you have that
experience and in my vibration lowers
and then I'm no longer available for
what God spirit Buddha Krishna Jesus and
Allah all of the above is trying to
speak to through and as me okay I have
to say that now we're we're good I love
it do preach it's great there's gotta be
that people should wake up to that
that's a good alarm clock
we need that that 45 second mini rant
there's the press and smiles alarm clock
even the fact that you you know has a
community to say I still need this
myself like I find mice even though
you're the master you to teach you
you're coaching people in this I still
need to remind of myself every day every
hour to focus on this I think it's
important man I think it's super
important yeah man I've become a dad
since the last time we spoke a dad of
three so we had twin a boy and a girl
and their three months and I have a
two-year-old and in his pure chaos and
pandemonium at our house I was just
watching the twins while my wife went to
the beach to just have some time to be a
regular person and it's crazy it's like
legit crazy
and the most beautiful thing and the
most it's a beautiful time to have twins
right I have all this space an
opportunity to just drop in and connect
and go deeper with them and have them
teach me right
that's the tricky thing about kids and I
know you know this is we think that they
belong to us and that we're here to
teach them but what really comes through
more and more as I pay attention and I
allow myself to be affected
by my children they're teaching me how
to be present they're teaching me how to
be patient they're teaching me how to be
curious about everything I just took my
son for a walk literally right before we
didn't you and I were messaging I was on
that one and he decided that we were no
longer gonna be walking it's like
straight that we had to one so we were
walking like this
Oh like down our whole neighborhood
backwards and every time I turned around
he'd be like okay okay but like new and
interesting perspective right yeah yeah
yeah the creativity the creativity the
freedom right and your the freedom guy
right
personal freedom coach yes sir but but
the reminder to be free I love it too
you know whether it's going to the store
dressed up like a superhero or you know
all of it all of it I love it I have my
parents on the wall behind me like this
pictures me when I'm eight or nine years
old and my parents above me and and the
greatest thing that they gave me was you
could do anything you want like you said
you believed in yourself you could do
anything you want and I have two sisters
I'm in the middle and we're all doing
totally different things and so my son
people asked me does he have to be not
friendly I don't care if he's an
entrepreneur like what does he want to
do he's he's he loves drawing and he
loves art and so I'm doing art with him
I'm trying to a nice suck at art trying
to draw human eye is ridiculously
impossible daddy he's already better
than me but it's fun like it's like last
time I sat down to draw something yep
yeah I'm gonna fight even if I never end
up drawing again it's still just
exercising that part of the the brain
the muscle that kind of got lost that
was you know what's interesting about
kids right so I teach which I got from
my mentor Michael Beckwith the four
stages of consciousness like Bumi by me
through me as me four stages of
consciousness four stages of awareness
and they aren't necessarily is like a
ladder it's cyclical right we're
bouncing in and out well what I noticed
is that my children mainly operate from
the third and fourth stage which is
through me
and as management they have no concept
of and when they do like for instance I
was playing catch with my son yesterday
and I threw the thing and I said catch
and he just motor skills or whatever II
wouldn't call it it just right the face
and goes into crying and feeling it and
he has that look first he's like should
I cry is this is this the moment where I
lose my right and so I notice how he
transitions out of that victim state
after just a second right it's crazy
kisses booboo I'm sorry buddy I didn't
mean to hit you
daddy apologizes right big hug
instantly wanting to play catch again
and so this is to me nature children and
old people are the three greatest
teachers we ever had right right old
people
I love old grumpy grandparents because
they only speak truth they no longer
care what people they've returned and
refunded everything that they've given
and now they are they're no longer
willing to play any other games other
than the one that's in alignment with
them and so to me that that's personal
freedom is being able to shoot alignment
and congruence at any given point at any
given moment and having the awareness to
say ah I'm in victim consciousness right
now or I'm in by me I'm trying to hustle
my way to this thing I'm trying to will
it with distance instead of being the
existence and the beacon that has that
happen no matter what so where do you
think we lose it along the way I think
that one of the worst things that we
hear as kids and especially as little
boys is what are you going to be when
you grow up and you hear that enough it
starts to denote this idea that there's
one thing that you have one like okay so
philosophically speaking this is my
opinion we all only have one purpose and
that is to reflect and reveal the cosmos
reflect and reveal God's love
in a way in which a unique way and only
which we can that's our purpose now my
vision and my mission changes on it on a
need-to-know basis it changes daily
based on what I have in front of me and
based on what I've cast it as my future
but my purpose is still to reflect and
reveal God's love along that whole
journey and so from a Western standpoint
we we hear so much that there's this
thing that you need to be when you grow
up and this there's it's always over
there it's this layaway plan where it's
over there over there is when I'll be
good enough over there is when I'll be a
big boy over there is when when I'm like
all of it and it's absolute bull and
what's powerful about people like
yourself and people like me who have
dedicated our lives to this I do this no
matter what I do when nobody's looking
at you when everybody's looking I lived
this rank is we're getting to enough
people right we already have the global
mind which is the internet now we have
the global heart which is you and I and
a bunch of us who've linked together and
said let's do this let's let's let's be
in no matter what let's be a rain
sunshine sleet whatever it is I'm
showing up and not just to tell people
not just to be the messenger but to be
the type of person whose life is a
demonstration of that bro that it gets
me so fired up there's so many things
that nobody ever sees but I take into
account just for my kids alone just want
my kids to say hey daddy you handle this
and I say you know what this is this is
how I was being during those times and
for them to just experience it just me
as a man and saying wow that's that's
integrity right there
that dude Falls he he does stupid stuff
but every time he catches it gets back
up and takes it to another level Twitty
what do you think is uh I mean I think
everybody can relate to that you see the
comments he probably this guy's bulk
this guy's let press and dropping bombs
for the person who's watching even here
on
- who's feeling yeah you're 100% true
but how do i how do I break it what's
the what's an exercise is it go jump in
a puddle is it is it like draw draw like
what what do I do
what's it what's an easy first step I
just realized you just told me that I'm
basically living under miles of mud
above me that I need to break through
and get my freedom you know what's my
first like stab at it to try to get back
to freedom okay so I'm about to go super
deep and I don't I don't know if you
guys want to go here but we're gonna go
let's do it don't every human has that
we all have desires right it comes with
the human the distinction and the
difference between a human that's living
an extraordinary life and a human that's
living an ordinary life or a life of
quiet desperation is where they're
getting that where they're checking the
box off from most humans go outside in
and even those who are aware enough to
say oh like by me stage right we go into
that Grant Cardone that Gary Vee stage
oh I'm gonna hustle hustle hustle I can
go make this money there's still a slave
to the money the money owns them the job
owns of the woman owns them the man owns
them the religion all of them every want
everyone to every desire goes under
these three categories approval control
or security security also known as
safety we talk about what's the word
financial security
relational security Thanks this is this
is encoded in our DNA because if I don't
feel safe if if I'm not safe then the
saber-tooth tiger can come and get me so
therefore my next process would be to
have you approve of blue right to want
you to like love and and belong to be a
part of something because if you kick me
out of a cave then my chances of
survival go down big-time right then
with these as to the third which is
control which is most of most of us are
frickin control freaks even this
conversation I'm doing my best to not
try to lead it
however there is an aspect of my wounded
ego that wants to look good that wants
to control how you guys perceive me
right so the game and this goes back to
inside out or outside in because it's
very subtle
right it's big and subtle the game is to
learn like oh when I don't feel approved
of therefore I don't feel safe I'm
moving to these control mechanisms where
I try to control god people food when I
eat when I waiter where I where I live
everything what my beard looks like all
of it isn't is a is a tactic for you to
like me so that I feel safe but all of
it is out there to hear and the power
isn't going okay I accept that that's a
part of the wiring that came with human
and let me do a fact check because most
humans never fact check their lives now
this is where we're going practical here
guys what's true now okay so I'm gonna
go through those three again am i safe
because going back to the at our lives a
thousand deaths the mind can make you
believe you're not safe when you
actually are right now am i safe hmm to
the best of my ability I believe I am
okay so check one check make or P not
out there I don't need it out there I
just checked it here do I approve of me
do I am i a good person do I believe in
my heart of hearts that I'm doing the
best that I can from where I can with
the tools and consciousness I have
available yes okay that's two now now
two times now we're talking about two
two of the biggest things I am now
checking from the inside out not over
there number three is everything that
can be in control in control can being
the operative word
some things we do need to control but
not all of them
hmm let's see did I brush my teeth
yes did I put on underwear yeah control
that kukuku
am i positioning myself to give my gifts
to the world
yep can control that fantastic so all
three boxes the most major ones in the
whole world are checked off from here to
there not there to here I'm telling you
if you work with that alone
this distinction will change your life
forever I do it 30 times a day I stopped
I used to have alarms in my phone every
time the alarm would go off I'd stop and
ask myself do I approve of me first of
all I'd pay attention to what I'm
experiencing in my body oh okay
alarm went off I'm now experiencing
anxiety where did that come from
now I go into the past I was looking at
my follower count and I saw that I lost
a thousand and then I made up a story
that because I'm ex people don't like me
okay so I was giving my power prove
control and all to those likes and those
followers and therefore now I'm
experiencing anxiety okay
now is it true is it fact if any of that
actually true no going back to it do I
approve of me yes
am i safe yes can I control is
everything that can be in control in
control yes it yes it thank you God game
on now I let myself my body the cells of
my body experience deep and abiding
gratitude for having all of my needs met
in that moment do I have water yes
do I have food yes can I get yes whoa I
am blessed beyond measure and I wasn't
allowing myself to experience it based
on some followers that left my account
all right I love it dude list you had
you had my favorite comment while you
went on that great there was press
Tina's cooking he's cooking I love it
when we circle back quickly just to the
conversation around kids and
I'm just wanting type of thing called
play bigger kickers which are also like
things you can design in your
environment in your habits and your team
that trigger you to play bigger right
like you're going for a walk with your
kid you can just expect something crazy
to happen like hey Daniel let's walk
backwards hey Danny let's like play in
the sand or whatever how do you for
someone who's watching this movie for
the first time if they know your stuff
they're following it already like
they're expecting this for somebody
who's like mine is blowing first I'm
hearing this what's an easy kind of play
bigger kick or they could put in their
life too because they're they're they're
woke now they're listening to this
awesome and tomorrow they wake up and
they forgot the energy is gone you know
so what what do they have to put in
their routine in their environment or
what have you so that that's a that's a
daily consistent thing is that the alarm
that you're doing like what do you
recommend yeah so so in some of these
people are in this actual thing I see
them I have a program called amplify and
it's about raising your vibration and
manifesting the life of your dreams one
of the things that we do in that program
is I have them and this happens week one
is I have everybody set what we call it
joy alarms though and the point of this
is to go into reasonless right I didn't
have a wreath and just decide that when
the alarm goes off like Pavlov's dogs I
am going to experience joy no matter
what I'm gonna choose it because I can
because I'm that powerful right so that
would be that would change your whole
life if you have how often how are you
doing it your life
well I do it all the time but I would
say starting out just three alarms three
to five morning
yep and and when that happens just go
bananas just decide that life is
beautiful and you can feel it and use
your body and let it like emanate off of
you and what happens is we just
literally we're reap a turning and and
rewiring and changing our personal
reality by changing our personality
which personality we all know or some do
some don't
is that our personality is based off of
our social and historical conditioning
it's based off of like the the beliefs
and interpretations that we were
learn in - and a lot of people never
question knows they never actually look
they never actually say wait this isn't
mine this is my mom's her mom's and her
mom's this isn't this is this is
belonging me to my dad's his dad's and
his dad's
but your job as a conscious choice maker
as a conscious creator on the planet
right now your job is to step forward
and say I'm gonna evolve the family I'm
gonna fall I'm gonna raise the bar and
decide them that that we're more we're
more than that then just pass down
traditions tradition is fantastic if it
serves you it's also bull if it doesn't
I'm not anything people ask me all the
time is your real name Preston smiles
yes it is but was I born Preston smiles
no I was born Preston Davis Davis being
a slave name where do you think they get
that they got that name somebody raped
my grandparents grandmother and beat out
of my grandfather probably
great-great-great-great that's how we
got Davis so do I identify with that
name no that tradition I'm Preston
smiles cuz I say so right
how old are you when you change any um
it was given to me by a janitor at a
college that I went to I was 22 when she
she called me that I was running down
the hall and she was like boy you always
run around his smiling I'm gonna call
you Preston smiles but you'll have
myself and it was one of those moments
where I was like that's my name I didn't
take it until I was 25 yeah but it it's
stuck at 22 I love I love it so much I
love salacious dude it's crazy time
flies when you're having fun we have for
people who want to dive deeper into your
world learn more about what you're doing
whether this program you're coaching
which really didn't end up talking about
your book all of it like what's where do
you want to know what's the best part
yeah just at Preston smiles man I mean
you know I appreciate anything and I'm
also not attached right in a way I coach
coaches and I help them build businesses
and all that stuff and one of the things
we talk about all the time is high
intent
low attachment I have a high intention
to to anybody who has ears to hear and
vibrates at the level that I vibrate at
bring it and you don't own me you don't
have my power I don't need your money
without what I love is to work with
people who are high dumb and committed
to taking their lives to the next level
and so if that's you at Preston smiles
you can find me there appreciate it
we'll pop that in the subscription to
for the youtubers dude pre shake you man
I think you are you're doing and and now
birthing three new humans into the world
we're gonna spread even more smiles
around the planet let's say thank you so
much good stuff bro I Love You Man I
love you too John if you want to see the
last time I spoke with Preston and his
amazing wife Alexia about the five
success habits that you need to have
check out the videos right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there